EQUIVALENT TO BEING CALLED A
PEDOPHILE.
THE AUTHOR IS JOHN McWHORTER, A
COLUMN FOR "THE NEW YORK TIMES."
JOHN, I READ AND THOROUGHLY
ENJOYED THE BOOK.
AS I WAS READING IT THIS WEEK I
THOUGHT OF YOU BECAUSE THE NAACP
CAME OUT WITH AN ANNOUNCEMENT,
THEY SAID IF YOU'RE AN ATHLETE
DON'T SIGN WITH A TEXAS TEAM
BECAUSE OF VOTING AND ABORTION
LAWS IN TEXAS.
I THOUGHT TO MYSELF, HOW FAR
REMOVED ARE WE WHERE AN ATHLETE
SIGNS WITH A TEXAS TEAM, AND
THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN, SOMEONE
SAYS, WELL, YOU'RE A RACIST
BECAUSE DIDN'T YOU GET THE NAACP
MEMO?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, ACTUALLY, I
WOULD SAY THAT I OF SOMEBODY OF
THE LEFT AND QUITE DISMAYED WITH
THINGS THAT HAVE HAPPENED IN
TEXAS, AND I UNDERSTAND WHERE
THAT CALL CAME FROM.
BUT IT IS PART AND PARCEL FROM
THE GENERAL SENSE THAT ONE MUST
GO ABOUT NOT ONLY KIND OF
CHECKING YOURSELF FOR RACISM.
BUT THE IDEA IS IF IN ANY SENSE
YOU ARE SEEN WITH COMPLYING WITH
THE SYSTEM, THEN YOU'RE SOME
KIND OF MORAL PERVERT.
THAT IT ISN'T ENOUGH TO BE A
NORMAL PERSON THAT THERE HAS TO
BE THIS GIANT PSYCHOLOGICAL
REVOLUTION.
I DON'T THINK ANYONE EVER
THOUGHT THIS IS THE WAY THE
SOCIETY SHOULD BE ONE IN THE
WHOLE SPECIES.
I HAVEN'T HEARD OF ANY
JUSTIFICATION AS TO WHY WE HAVE
TO CONDUCT OURSELVES THAT WAY
NOW, AS OPPOSED TO DOING THINGS
ON THE GROUND TO HELP PEOPLE WHO
NEED HELP.
>> AUDIENCE FOR THIS BOOK ARE
NOT THOSE THAT YOU'RE
CRITICIZING, RIGHT?
IT'S THE PEOPLE YOU'RE TRYING TO
COUNSEL, I'LL SAY, THE REST OF
US, AS TO HOW DO WE RESPOND?
DO WE RESPOND AT ALL?
DO WE RESPOND KNOWING WE MIGHT
BE CALLED A RACIST FOR DOING SO?
>> YEAH.
I THINK THAT IF YOU KNOW THAT
YOU ARE CHECKING YOURSELF FOR
RACISM, AND YOU'RE DOING THINGS
TO HELP PEOPLE WHO WILL NEED
HELP, AS OPPOSED TO THE VIRTUE
SIGNAL THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
TOLD WHAT THEY NEED TO DO.
IF YOU'RE DOING THOSE THINGS I
AM ASKING WHITE AMERICANS TO
GETTING USED TO BEING CALLED
RACIST BY A CERTAIN VOCAL
MINORITY OF PEOPLE WHO THINK
IT'S THEIR JOB TO CALL PEOPLE
NAMES AND MAKE PEOPLE CRY IN THE
NAME OF TURNING THE COUNTRY
UPSIDE DOWN AND MAKING EVERYBODY
GO THROUGH THIS SOCIAL
REVOLUTION.
WE HAVE TO GET USED TO CALLING
NAMES AND GO OFF AND DO THE WORK
THAT WE DO.
WE CAN'T LET THAT PARTICULAR
PERSON BE IN CHARGE, BECAUSE
THEY'LL BASICALLY RUIN ALL OF
OUR LIVES AND INFILTRATE OUR
INSTITUTIONS AND TURN US INTO
CHINA DURING THE CULTURAL
REVOLUTION, ANALOGOUSLY, NOT
PHYSICAL VIOLENCE BUT THE WHOLE
IDEA IS THAT SAME SORT OF THING.
>> THERE'S A CHART IN THE BOOK.
YOU ACTUALLY PUBLISH IT TWICE
FOR EMPHASIS.
YOU CALL IT A CATECHISM OF
CONTRADICTIONS.
I'LL READ ONE THAT I CIRCLED.
IF YOU'RE WHITE AND DATE ONLY
WHITE PEOPLE, YOU'RE A RACIST.
BUT IF YOU'RE WHITE AND DATE A
BLACK PERSON, YOU ARE, IF NOT
ONLY DEEP DOWN, EXOTIFYING AN
"OTHER."
WHAT'S GOING ON THERE?
>> I WANT PEOPLE TO ME STOP
SAYING YOU CAN SAY BOTH OF THOSE
THINGS AND HOW IT'S SOMEWHAT
DEEP CALLED THE RACE THING THAT
YOU HAVE TO STUDY THE WAY YOU
STUDY QUANTUM PHYSICS.
IT'S ALSO NOT FAIR.
BOTH OF THOSE STATEMENTS ARE
DESIGNED FOR PEOPLE TO SHOW THAT
THEY KNOW RACISM EXISTS OR CAN
EXIST.
IF THAT'S THE ONE THING YOU'RE
DEVOTED FOR YOU CAN SAY BOTH OF
THOSE COMPLETELY CONTRADICTORY
THINGS AND FEEL LIKE YOU'RE
DOING A JOB.
IF THE TWO CANCEL EACH OTHER
OUT, NO MATTER HOW NOBLE YOU
FEEL, THOSE THICKS DON'T MAKE
SENSE.
IT'S GOT TO BE ONE OR THE OTHER
OR MAYBE NEITHER.
THE IDEA THAT YOU'RE DATING A
BLACK PERSON AND YOU'RE RACIST
OR NOT DATE A BLACK PERSON AND
YOU'RE RACISM.
THAT'S WHY WE SAY TALKING ABOUT
RACE IS COMPLICATED.
WHEN OFTEN THE WAY WE'RE
ENCOURAGED TO TALK ABOUT DOESN'T
MAKE ANY SENSE.
I WANT OUR RACE CONVERSATIONS TO
MAKE SENSE.
>> ANOTHER VIGNETTE FROM THE
BOOK.
PUT THIS UP ON THE SCREEN.
A FRIEND WROTE IN FACEBOOK THAT
THEY AGREE BLACK LIVES MATTER
BLACK LIVES MATTER ONLY WILL BE
ROASTED BY AN ANONYMOUS PERSON.
WAIT A MINUTE, YOU AGREE WITH
THEM?
THAT IMPLIES YOU GET TO DISAGREE
WITH THEM.
THAT'S LIKE YOU AGREE WITH THE
LAW OF GRAVITY.
YOU AS A WHITE PERSON DON'T GET
TO AGREE OR DISAGREE WHEN BLACK
PEOPLE ASSERT SOMETHING.
SAYING YOU AGREE WITH THEM IS
EVERY BIT AS ARROGANT AS
DISPUTING THEM.
THIS ISN'T AN INTELLECTUAL
EXERCISE.
THIS IS THEIR LIVES ON THE LINE.
YOUR REACTION?
>> YEAH, I FEEL CONDESCENDING TO
ON THAT.
THE PROBLEM IS, IF YOU EXCEPT
ABSOLUTELY EVERYTHING THAT A
BLACK PERSON SAYS, YOU'RE
DEHUMANIZING THEM YOU'RE PITYING
THEM AND PITY IS NOT HONOR.
ALL PEOPLE MAKE MISTAKES
INCLUDING PEOPLE WHO ARE THE
DESCENDANTS OF AFRICAN SLAVES
BROUGHT TO THIS COUNTRY TO
ENDEAR SLAVERY AND JIM CROW AND
REDLINING.
THERE'S NO SUCH THING AS PERFECT
PEOPLE.
AND HAVE THIS NOTION THAT
ANYTHING THAT A BLACK PERSON IS
TO BE BOWED DOWN TO.
AND THIS IS NOT WHAT THIS IS
ABOUT.
THIS IS SUPPOSED TO BE ABOUT
HELPING, ESPECIALLY POOR PEOPLE
WITH THE PROBLEMS IN THEIR
LIVES.
ALL OF THE REST OF THIS IS PLAY
ACTING AND FRANKLY, IT'S
EXTREMELY FAKE AND
CONDESCENDING.
>> JOHN, CAN I SAY I LIKE HAVING
THIS DIALOGUE.
I REALLY DO.
I KNOW WHEN I HAVE IT, OF
COURSE, YOU GET CALLED A RACIST
FOR EVEN ENGAGING IN THIS
DIALOGUE.
IT GOES WITH THE TERRITORY IF
YOU DO WHAT I DO FOR A LIVING OR
YOU DO FOR A LIVING.
MY FEAR IS, FOR THE REMINDER OF
SOCIETY, JUST TO TAKE A PASS,
OH, MAN, I AM NOT EVEN GOING TO
TALK ABOUT THESE THINGS BECAUSE
I DON'T WANT TO BE CALLED THAT
WORD.
AND YOU SAY NO, WE'VE GOT TO
HAVE THIS CONVERSATION.
GREAT BOOK.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
I HOPE THE EMAILS GO TO YOU AND
NOT TO ME, OKAY?
>> WE'LL SEE, THANK YOU.
>> OKAY.
>>> CHECKING IN ON YOUR TWEETS
AND FACEBOOK COMMENTS WHAT DO WE
HAVE?
FROM THE WORLD OF TWITTER.
WOW, THAT'S A LONG ONE.
THIS PART OF OUR NATION'S
HISTORY IS AWFUL BUT MY CHILDREN
AND GRANDCHILDREN SHOULD NOT
FEEL GUILTY FOR WHAT OCCURRED.
THE CONVERSATION NEEDS TO BE
MADE FOR SCHOOL QUALITY.
THE WAY FOR ADVANCEMENT IS
THROUGH EDUCATIONAL ACHIEVEMENT
AND NOT CURRICULUM.
I SHOULD HAVE SAID THIS, HIS
SOLUTION TO THIS ISSUE IS THREE
THINGS.
STOP THE WAR ON DRUG US.
TE